the 20 series is finally out but
unfortunately all the cards out right
now are really overpriced for the
performers that they provide however
while the GTX 2016 exception to that
[Music]
welcome to Harvey's hobbies so first of
all let's take a look at the expected
performance of the GTX 2060 this is the
performance isn't good then there is no
point in even considering the card in
the first place so far with all the
cards are out right now
like the r-tx 2080 TI and 2080 we have
seen some great improvement over last
generation for example the r-tx 2080 TI
is about 30% faster than the gtx 980ti
and there are several leaks out there
suggesting the gtx 2060 will be greater
than or equal to the performance of the
GTX 280 it may not be as high as that
but I would definitely say that the GTX
2060 will perform better than gtx 1070
but maybe not opportunity to write about
the GTA 1070 TI level
so overall the GTX 2060 should
definitely be a significant operator of
the GTX 260
but what real-world performance of that
actually translated into well the GTX
2060 should be able to completely
obliterate all games at 1080p with max
settings for the next couple of years it
is more of a 1440p or 1080p ultra wide
gaming card supported those gaming
styles expect around 60 to 90 frames per
second on on games with mac settings
unfortunately it will struggle with 4k
on certain games may be able to push on
60 frames but for the most part it will
be less than 60 frames per second as far
as 4k goes overall the GTX 2060 will
pretty much be an overkill 1080p gaming
card that will last you several years or
an OnPoint 1440p or 1080p
ultra wide gaming card that will also
last several years but you may have to
dial in the graphic settings after a
couple of years I think the next most
important factor when concerned to buy a
card is its price so will the GTX 2060
be super expensive
like it's r-tx brothers first of all the
gtas 2060 does not have a great racing
technology and that probably contributed
very heavily to the higher price of the
RT x series NVIDIA spent several years
developing that technology so the
research costs were probably very high
and that may be a huge factor as to why
the RT X series is so expensive but the
GTX 2060 doesn't have very crazy
technology to actually be able to save a
bunch of money on that also this is just
a mid-level part so and you can't really
push the price up very much without
losing out on a lot of potential
customers that being said I think the GT
2060 will come out for an MSRP of $300
because that's exactly MSRP than gtx
1066 goodbye car also came out for and
unfortunately I really don't think
you'll be lower than that especially
because of the RAM situation right now
and it may even be up to three hundred
four dollars for the Constitution card
but for the most part the GT is 2060
should be relatively the same price the
GTX 1060 which cannot be said about the
twenty series cards that are out right
now it was expected the GTX 2060 would
come out at the end of November or the
beginning of December that way Nvidia
and we could both take advantage of the
holiday season and drive more sales for
them and get really great prices for us
but fortunately that does not seem to be
happening right now
according to Asus the GTX 2060 is not
set out to come until the first quarter
of 2019 this does make sense because
Nvidia still has a lot of inventory of
the 10 series and so they definitely
don't want to saturate the market with
more options so unfortunately there's
probably still a couple of months before
we even hear about this card in the
meantime something that you should
definitely not overlook is the 10 series
this 10 series car still performing
great and there are really great deals
out there right now by the end of this
year we will probably see record low
prices for all the 10 series GPUs
especially throughout the holiday season
a baby wiser to pick up a GTX 1070 or
1080 do you want these great deals
instead of waiting for the GTX 2060
because you may even be able to get
cheaper price for just about the same
performance and you will have to wait as
long to you just won't be on the newest
platform and get some of the little
benefits of the 20 series well if you
don't really care about those and you
just care about rock performance then
this is really a great deal because the
10 series is still a great series that
will last you many many years the GTX
2060 will most likely be a solid upgrade
over 1064 around the same price but
unfortunately it is probably still a
couple of months out right now if you
are not an in Russian you want the
newest thing it is definitely worth it
to wait for it
you will not regret it however if you
really don't care about that and just
care about value and performance then 10
series is still a great option but that
just what I think what do you guys think
when do you guys think the gtas 2060 is
going to come out and do you relate it
to rx 600 series or whatever it will be
called is actually coming out next month
and what about aimed in ami make sure to
comment down below what you guys think
because I do read all my comments and
cues as to what you think - make sure to
post your thoughts also you guys like
this video make sure drop a like and
consider subscribing if you'd like to
see more videos just like this one but
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
the next one
[Music]